well today could see another step in an
era of massive change in Germany's
energy sector the federal government
wants to close the country's opencast
lignite mines Germany's coal Commission
is meeting in Berlin today to decide the
way forward and there is a lot at stake
around 21,000 jobs depend directly on
that form of coal if you add in the
suppliers of and subcontractors the
number is more like 70,000 jobs and
that's not all
lignite coal is still the source for 22
percent of energy production in Germany
so it's an ambitious goal to replace
that with renewables in just a few years
we'll get more on the Commission's
decision from our correspondent in just
a moment but first let's take a look at
one of the area's most affected by this
transition the lusatia region in eastern
Germany with its long coal mining
tradition for 150 years the lusatia
region that straddles the German Polish
border has stood for brown coal mining
the town of lemberg on the German side
of the divide is typical of the area we
a cocina han chaeah fears a move away
from coal will mean massive job losses
this is a question of survival because
if you can't guarantee people's
livelihoods
if you cannot create economic prospects
people will leave and they will leave
faster before the actual exit from coal
has taken place at its peak this
coal-fired power plant known as the
schwate pumpa or black pump had 17,000
employees today only 5,000 people work
in the industrial park and that's why
many are afraid they are skeptical about
the prospects for a future without coal
mining industry replaces coal mining
Shore if not then I highly doubt that
comeback will stay the way it is that
appreciates we hope to ISM will become
our next source of income but of course
no one knows whether that will happen
many people are leaving stromberg to
find work bidding
especially young people and in humanoid
but some young people have decided to
stay four months ago Anja Keith's leash
rush Bloomberg native opened an
advertising agency she receives many
orders from the coal industry from my
point of view we're in the middle of a
structural change we must accept this
and recreate things to suit our needs we
have to look to the future uh Nikolas
represents the new SH Bloomberg the
trained media designer wants to set an
example especially for young people if
people do stay here then the
self-proclaimed pearl of lusatia will
have a future even without coal the
motto for EM bear could be move forward
creatively stay here in lusatia but
think up a new future so that the peril
can continue to shame Germany wants to
phase out coal power a chance to start
something new but many people fear it
will be at their cost no one really
knows what industry will replace coal
and what will fill the void he wrench
blim back and that expert commission I
mentioned earlier is meeting here in
Berlin at the Chancellery our political
correspondent Hans bunt is there
following the summit for us he's
standing just outside of Hans
I can see that a demonstration is taking
place there who's protesting and what
are they calling for I can hardly hear
because it's so loud around the at the
moment but this coal Commission that has
been set up by the government and is
trying to bring together representatives
from all areas of the society that are
interested in this subject and trying to
find a final solution to how coal as a
power source can be ended in Germany as
you can see from this demonstration here
one aspect of this is that there are
young people in Germany that are pushing
for an exit from coal for coal not to be
used for power generation as quickly as
possible
immediately basically on the other hand
you have interest groups such as the
trade
who represent people working in this
industry and of course the power
generating companies who are saying that
this should be a process that should be
done gradually for from their side as
slowly as possible basically and at the
same time they are saying it's a process
that needs to be controlled very very
carefully and it's still likely to take
a long time now the expert Commission on
coal that's meeting there in the
Chancellery has a tough job trying to
deliver a swift exit from coal while
avoiding economic collapse and regions
like like we just saw in our report
there in loose Asia these regions are
dependent on coal how is this commission
supposed to square that circle I'm
afraid I didn't get that question I
couldn't understand the question just
wondering hands
wondering about that coal Commission
they have to try to get Germany to
weaned off coal while preventing
economic collapse in regions dependent
on coal just how they are going to do
that well this is a fact what we are all
wondering at you know one of the things
that the regions that are dependent on
coal which are mostly in in the eastern
part of Germany what they are demanding
is that when this coal industry stops
working there when the jobs that are in
the coal industry some few thousand are
no longer available that the government
should make available billions of euros
to try and set up new industry there and
to support the people that are working
there to support the economy in that
region the question one of the questions
is how much money is going to be made
available by the government and how long
this is going to take at the moment the
region's concerned are demanding tens of
billions of euros in support the
government has not so far said there
what amount of money it will make
available and that in fact is one of the
figures that one is expecting this coal
commission to come up with - thank you
so much for now DW DW political
correspondent hunt
[Music]
you